i genuinely don't know at this point in
time
um
what is
the belief of stephen bannon
about something they called the
certification decertification is a word
that bannon and people like my pillow
ceo mike lindell we we just know him as
pillow
um what have they been
uh what how seriously do they believe
that states can or might decertify the
2020 election results this is not going
to happen we're almost at the next
election but steve bannon continues to
talk about it so i want to play this
clip for you people who are watching
might realize steve bannon is a just a
spitting image of b arthur at this point
it's a very very strange physical
appearance of steve bannon and that's
sort of out of school i don't really
know what to make of it but let's focus
in on what steve bannon says here listen
to what he says
of these electors and that's what
remember let's get our language very
specific we're not asking and we've
never asked for president trump's never
asked for it this movement's never asked
for it to change the election and to
flip it to donald j trump that is just
not the right nomenclature it's not the
right language
what we've asked for is very similar
that only certifiable
constitutional
legal chain of custody votes from
american citizens can be counted for the
november 2020 election now of course
that's exactly what happened there has
been no evidence that votes that should
not be counted were counted so so far
i'm with bannon only valid votes should
be counted
and we have evidence that only valid
votes were counted good
once they're counted right in an
accurate way
and real votes not things that came with
their machines although i'm not a
machine guys people know but once we get
everything remember mike pillow wants to
sue all machines
okay that's the election and we know now
whether it is in pennsylvania whether it
is in uh whether it's in wisconsin
arizona or georgia those four states
alone
we understand right now and i think
eventually nevada nevada and michigan
but those four states alone we can move
right now the state legislature to
decertify to decertify the electors not
to flip the election to decertify the
electors and do what the constitution
says flip it to the house of
representatives where you vote by uh you
vote by delegation state by state and of
course we control what 26 or 27 of those
delegations okay so again
bannon is saying
states can say our electors weren't
valid
and then
you instead of going by
electoral votes
each state gets one vote for who should
be president 26 states out of 50 will
say we believe trump and then trump
becomes the president this is not going
to happen first of all
we are almost at the next election
what is it now uh eight months seven and
a half months from the midterms but
putting that aside
everything bannon says in this clip is
untrue and i don't know if bannon really
believes what he's saying there is no
legal basis to uh decertify um a state's
election or electors there's just
it's just not a thing
there is no provision in the united
states constitution that says
if states quote decertify their electors
then anything happens joe biden is
president to remove joe biden he would
need to die
um the 25th amendment could be used
or he could be
convicted on impeachment
those are the three ways that you can
quote remove the president
and in any of those three situations the
vice president would assume the
presidency
so
what bannon is talking about doesn't
exist and the most important
consideration here is imagine that even
though there is no such process as the
the decertification imagine some state
invented it and created it
if a state
did it and again what it what it means
isn't even clear but if a state were to
decertify now in march almost april of
2022
it would have no legal significance it's
not like even if you go and follow this
imagine that four states call up who do
you even call i guess you call up the
senate i don't even know who do you tell
you call someone in dc
and you say
sirs and mams we've decertified our
election from our electors from 2020.
you think washington dc goes oh okay
well let's just redo this thing and
we'll have each state get one vote of
course not there is no such process and
it's not in the electoral account act of
1887
um it has no provision for
decertification that uh the for the 1887
legislation or or
structure on which this is all based so
again my question to you is do you think
steve bannon really believes any of this
stuff uh make sure that you see these
clips on our instagram which you can
find at david pakman show
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something
really useful and very practical or
let's say i'm ordering food over the
phone
but i left my wallet somewhere i don't
have my real credit card on me i can use
a virtual card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft
privacy is a totally free service and
you'll get five bucks to spend when you
go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video